[Música]
les doy la bienvenida al espacio de
cultura de France 24 la novelista
francesa añade no es la ganadora del
premio Nobel de literatura 2022 según
sus propias palabras se trata de un gran
honor y además una gran responsabilidad
para defender la justicia y la equidad
con las mujeres y con los dominados de
un 82 años es también catedrática y
profesora de letras modernas y se ha
destacado por una escritura en primera
persona de la memoria feminista y de un
gran compromiso social Luis Muñoz nos
adentra en su figura
en sus propias palabras sanier no es una
escritora auto sociobiográfica también
feminista y la academia sueca le ha
otorgado el premio Nobel de literatura
por el coraje y la perspicacia clínica
con la que descubre las raíces la
lejanía y las limitaciones colectivas de
la memoria personal
con más de una veintena de libros
escritos su escritura ha hecho énfasis
en la intimidad y sus propios
pensamientos y quizás el verdadero
objetivo de mi vida sea este que mi
cuerpo mi sensaciones y mis pensamientos
se conviertan en escritura es decir en
algo inteligible y general y que mi
existencia pase a disolverse
completamente en la cabeza y en la vida
de los otros
ha sido considerada como una guardiana
de la memoria escogemos nuestros objetos
y lugares de memoria o más bien el
espíritu de la época decide que merece
ser recordado además describir
sociología literaria con énfasis en sus
propios orígenes de clase trabajadora
nunca pensé que las diferencias
provinieran del dinero creía que era
algo innato la pulcritud o la mugre el
gusto por las cosas bonitas o la dejadez
las borracheras el fiambre enlatado el
papel de periódico enganchado a un clavo
junto al retrete creía que era una
elección que eran felices así hacen
falta un montón de reflexiones las
estructuras clases para no pensar de esa
manera sobre todo cuando se es una niña
y siempre ha sido así tanto en sus
libros como en sus declaraciones siempre
se ha mostrado abiertamente feminista
así habló en una entrevista de archivo
para france24 ha habido siempre fuerzas
reaccionarias para querer mantener el
cuerpo de las mujeres porque es de eso
que se trata de mantener el cuerpo de
las mujeres bajo la voluntad y la mirada
de los hombres él no es la decimoséptima
mujer en la historia en recibir un
premio Nobel de literatura mientras que
ya son 16 los franceses que han recibido
el galardón en toda la historia
vamos ahora a Nueva York que en Estados
Unidos donde un éxito son musical
celebrará el mes de la herencia hispana
Mulan huye el musical la adaptación en
el escenario de la icónica película de
Batman organizó una noche
latinoamericana a finales de septiembre
y ofrece hasta el 21 de diciembre
descuentos especiales en boletos como
gesto de gratitud con las audiencias de
la comunidad Latina y con los miembros
del elenco que tienen raíces latinas nos
dará corresponsal mamen sala discutó con
los integrantes de Los vínculos entre
mulang el musical y latinoamérica con
una famosa canción Desde police
especialmente en mente
[Música]
necesitas el tango argentino para
roxanne es el latido de toda esa sección
Honestamente es mi parte favorita del
espectáculo y es tan hermoso y está
también hecho
coreografía da una gran representación
de lo que es el tango y creo que es
Honestamente la parte más emocionante
del espectáculo y es como la joya
escondida Así es como me gusta llamar
[Música]
me encanta tener esa representación de
nuestra cultura latinoamericana aquí en
el show pero no nada más se refleja en
esa pieza Yo creo que el show tiene
tanta diversidad
diferentes tipos de danza diferentes
cuerpos en el show
los estilos musicales también varían de
un estilo al otro hay tanta diversidad
en el cast y en el show que sí se siente
como como casa
[Música]
la música no sigue acompañando para esta
última parte del programa dedicada a los
estrenos de la semana empezando con el
rey y su nuevo tema amor
odio y peligro en el videoclip la
exitosa belga de 26 años se transforma
en un teléfono gigante para hablar de la
dependencia que podemos tener con estos
objetos electrónicos la cantante
continúa su gira en Europa para su
segundo álbum donald's
[Música]
seguimos con estrenos que harán felices
a los fanáticos de rock con Woody Paint
los británicos de Arctic Monkeys ofrecen
el segundo título extracto de su séptimo
álbum previsto para finales de octubre
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y con This is white el grupo
estadounidense para amor concretizar su
vuelta y anuncia el tono de su primer
álbum en 5 años que se estrenará en
febrero de 2023
[Aplausos]
Nos despedimos con de Charco en Charco
la primera colaboración entre las
españolas Belén Aguilera y Samurai un
himno a la valentía y al atrevimiento
Gracias a ustedes por su confianza y
sigan con nosotros hay más cultura en
las 24 y France 24.com
[Música]